our daily cancellation today has evolved
quite a bit
um or maybe it's more true to say that
it has
metamorphosed into a beautiful
ill-tempered butterfly however you want
to put it
i had planned today to cancel the cia
for its
now infamous woke recruitment ad
featuring a female cia agent who says
that she
is quote a cisgender millennial a woman
of color and
intersectional she also says that her
existence is not a box checking exercise
even as she proceeds to check every box
she can
now all of this is extremely stupid
worse than stupid when you consider that
the cia
is recruiting people who'd be better
suited teaching gender theory at
portland community college
where all the students should attend for
free says jill biden
but the worst part of the ad is when she
boasts about her generalized anxiety
disorder
this is a someone working for the cia
who's bragging about the fact that they
have anxiety disorder
and she includes it as one of the
identity boxes to check
so on her victimhood resume anxiety
disorder is listed right alongside a
woman of color and intersectional and
all the rest of it
this is what we've done in our society
we have turned things like anxiety into
mental disorders and then made mental
disorders trendy
something that people like this woman
quite literally advertise
and that's what sent me off in a
different direction as i thought about
it
i became less interested in the cia ad
and and more interested in this issue of
anxiety
and what we in modern culture have made
of it and that's what prompted me to
tweet the following thought last night
i said uh quote quoting myself one of
the worst things to happen in modern
times is the medicalization of the human
condition
now people who experience anxiety think
they're sick they aren't
anxiety is a fundamental fact of human
existence it is not a disease
that's what i wrote that's what i
believe we have set out to medicalize
and
diseaseify every aspect of the human
condition every difficult emotion
every unpleasant personality trait
that's why the dsm now has something
like 300 mental disorders listed and
over 50 million adults in this country
have been diagnosed with at least one of
them
now as you might expect that opinion
provoked an intense
and almost entirely negative reaction
almost entirely negative public reaction
i should qualify
i have gotten a lot of private messages
from people whispering their agreement
with me
saying hey i agree with you attaboy
thumbs up
but in public almost everyone who's
chimed in and contributed to discussion
has been of the opinion that i am wrong
and not only wrong but a filthy
worthless piece
of human dirt for even daring to say
something like this out loud
or tweet it out loud now i am saying it
out loud because the one way to ensure
that i keep saying something
and keep saying it louder and louder is
to demand that i stop saying it
yes that is that's that's the maturity
level for me
you tell me to stop saying it i'm going
to say it louder that's the way i work
now i'd like to explain my point of view
a little bit uh but i want to be clear
before i do that this explanation
is in no way an apology i don't
apologize
at all i'm really happy that i said what
i said and i couldn't have been more
right about it
and if you're someone who reacts to an
honest opinion by screaming and crying
and ranting and raving
the problem is you you in fact owe me an
apology for being so unreasonable and
annoying
so i accept your apology you are
forgiven
now let's move on to the actual issue
and as far as that goes a few points i
want to make
number one i have been accused of
stigmatizing mental illness with this
opinion i'm told the same whenever i
argue that adhd
is not a real mental illness which it
isn't not a real disorder which it isn't
but um what i'm doing is exactly the
opposite of stigmatizing
what i'm saying is that anxiety is an
inevitable part of being human it comes
with our consciousness
and self-awareness stigmatize no to
stigmatize is to say that it's weird or
embarrassing
if anything calling it a mental disorder
is stigmatizing
i'm also not minimizing anxiety i'm not
stigmatizing or minimizing
just because it comes with being human
doesn't mean that it's any less painful
difficult you know
sometimes overwhelming neither am i
saying that those struggling with their
anxiety shouldn't seek help again
just because anxiety is human doesn't
mean that we shouldn't that we that we
should wallow helplessly in it
so i'm not stigmatizing i'm not
minimizing and i'm not saying that
people shouldn't get help
i'm simply arguing that we have made a
category error we have placed anxiety
along with many other human emotions
and experiences like for example despair
into a medical box when it doesn't
belong there
two the idea that anxiety is a
fundamental fact of human existence a
defining fact actually
is not new or bold i wish i could take
credit for having this bold interesting
new opinion
i don't only the last 18 seconds or so
did we decide
as a country as a society
to start treating these things as
psychiatric disorders prior to the
medicalization push
anxiety was a subject for philosophers
and theologians and other great minds
this is not an argument from authority
my critics are the ones making arguments
from authority i'll get to that in a
minute but
my point is simply that what i'm saying
about anxiety
has been said or something very close to
it has been said by many people much
smarter than myself and much smarter
than you probably
all throughout history that doesn't mean
that i'm right
but it does mean that if you're shocked
by the idea that i present here
if you react to it like it's absurd or
outlandish
then i have to suspect that you really
haven't thought much about it or read
anything about it
if you'd spend any significant time
reflecting on anxiety and reading what
others have said about it throughout
history
then you certainly would have
encountered my point of view many times
and should not therefore be recoiling in
shock and horror
if you are recoiling shocking heart then
consider the possibility
that you haven't given this topic much
thought
number three i have been told that i am
not qualified to give my opinion on this
subject because i'm not a doctor but i
note with interest
that almost all of the people telling me
that i'm not qualified because i lack a
medical degree
also themselves lack a medical degree
turns out that you don't need a doctor
you don't need to be a doctor to have an
opinion you need to be a doctor to have
an opinion that differs from their own
that is an argument from authority and
it's also ad hoc
childish and stupid besides my point
here once again
is that this is not a medical issue
to demand my medical credentials is to
beg the question
you're expecting me to abide by your
premise but i'm rejecting your premise
that's the whole point of the arguments
doctors may be experts on medical
conditions but they're not experts on
the human
condition i'm not sure that anyone can
be an expert on that per se because they
can only experience their own humanity
and not anybody else's but i do think
that some people are blessed with wisdom
that gives them greater insight into the
subject than others
i don't think that doctors often have
that insight actually i think it's a big
problem
that doctors know about medical
conditions but they have
it seems often have very little
understanding of human nature and the
human condition
so for a greater understanding of that
of human nature in the human condition
for that you have to look to those great
philosophers theologians and other men
others mentioned earlier four finally
um there's a version of my argument
that would garner much wider approval
and agreement i think
if i had simply said that anxiety
disorder is over diagnosed
most people would probably agree say the
same about adhd
and depression and other similar things
uh and most people agree
if you say it's over diagnosed even
people who have been diagnosed
will usually agree though most of them
will say that other people have been
misdiagnosed not themselves so it's a
very odd problem apparently mental
disorders are being massively
misdiagnosed
but no individual person has been
misdiagnosed
quite a riddle isn't it now i think we
end up here because the general problem
is just undeniable as already mentioned
there are around 300 diagnosable mental
disorders and counting
300 different ways that your mind can be
considered disordered
sick diseased and now
50 million adults and 17 million
children have been diagnosed with at
least one of them
that doesn't make any intuitive sense
how can so many people
be mentally ill at a certain point if so
many people have disordered minds
doesn't the word disordered begin to
lose its meaning
to call something disordered you have to
have some idea of what the proper order
is so what is the properly ordered
mind and who has it because pretty soon
we get to the point where
nobody has one and if everybody has a
disorder
then it would seem like nobody does
the word just doesn't mean anything
anymore now this problem is apparent i
think to a lot of people and yet few
people want to really think about why
this is happening
how it has happened how to prevent it
from happening
all we're allowed to do all that most
people will allow themselves to do
is look at the problem from 30 000 feet
speak about it in very broad terms and
then ultimately shrug their shoulders
and
move on and do nothing about it to get
any more specific
to really dig down deep into the issue
is dangerous and upsetting and it
requires you to trample over
a whole lot of sacred cows so
let's trample them my view is that
mental disorders
are wide wildly over diagnosed and
misdiagnosed
because some of the most commonly
diagnosed mental disorders
do not belong in that category at all
anxiety is not the only example of this
but it's the one we're discussing today
when you take something like anxiety
which is absolutely essential to the
human experience
and you declare that when it's felt to a
certain degree
or reaches a certain amount it's
disordered and transforms from a human
emotion to a mental illness
you have opened up a floodgate that you
cannot close
you could say that anxiety is only
disordered when it causes problems in
this or that area of your life or is
experienced
for this or that reason or in this or
that way or whatever else but ultimately
these standards are going to always be
arbitrary and subjective
by definition it's not like diagnosing a
tumor or cardiovascular disease
you're attempting to diagnose the
content of someone's
consciousness you are diagnosing a
thought
process and yes anxiety is a thought
process now you might say oh it has
physical causes so on and so forth
it's a thought in other words a
non-thinking being
cannot be experiencing anxiety
if a if a if a person or being is not
thinking anything then it doesn't make
any sense to say that they're having
anxiety
anxiety is a thought process and that's
what you're diagnosing
it's a normal thought process one of the
most normal
most fundamental thought processes when
you start slapping medical
labels on normal if painful human
thoughts and emotions
eventually you'll have slapped a label
on every emotion and every person
and we we are well on our way to that
point
the only way to stop it is to radically
rethink our whole approach to mental
illness
we have to start reorganizing the
categories in a major way
we have to consider the possibility that
not everything which causes pain
is a sickness not every source of agony
is a disorder if we're not willing to
think about that or even to talk about
it
then the tide of medicalization and
pharmaceutical intervention will
continue to rise
until everyone is drowning in it
and for that reason today the cia is
cancelled
they weren't going to escape i was
coming back around to them
and so they're still canceled and uh you
know anxiety disorder is also cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated